Graphs A and D probably look pretty familiar to you and they go respectively
with functions G and F. I know it probably seems a little bit strange because
we haven't seen equations like these before, even though you recognize their
graphs. We'll talk more about this later, but start to think, right now, about
what these equations reduce to. And why they produce the graphs that they do.
Graphs B and C however are definitely new for us. Graph B represents the
function one over X and graph C represents the function one over X squared.
You'll see a lot more graphs that look like these two over the next few
lessons. And pretty soon you'll understand exactly what's happening in each of
them.